cactus only grows in deserts and we  won't see any leafy or flowering plants  grow there this is because of the soil  there are four basic types of soil that  have been categorized as per the size of  the soil particle  sandy soil it's the sand that you find  on beaches and deserts if you use a  microscope to view the particles they  are very big and hence they do not  retain water  silt soil the particles are smaller than  sand but still don't retain much water  it's the soil found near rivers and  moves with the waves  clay soil the particles are very small  and closely knit together hence it holds  most of the water poured in it it's used  in making earthen pots statues etc loamy  soil this is a mixed soil with some big  and small particles the water retention  is just perfect for growing vegetables  and is most preferred in agriculture do  you know why it's black tell us in the  comments section